okay so the long halloween is something
i'll always have fun memories of
growing up i read a lot of comics but as
i became a teenager i got interested in
other stuff
like collecting stamps and it wasn't
until my mid-20s that i started to pick
them back up again
the long halloween was the first book i
bought with this renaissance
and i read it cover to cover and
absolutely loved it
before starting out on youtube i used to
run a website in which i read through
every batman graphic novel
and also ranked them the long halloween
hit the top three only being
bested by the dark knight returns and
the cult and because of this when the
animated movie got announced i was more
worried than joker's plastic surgeon
i've been holding off and reviewing it
until both parts were released but i'm
happy to say that it's one of the best
dc animated movies ever
in this video we're going to be breaking
it all down and it'll be divided into
several parts with the first half
talking about the main plot of the work
as well as some of the major comic book
changes if you want to just skip ahead
to see us talk about the ending
and what happens next then time codes as
always will be linked below
now if this is your first time here then
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul and why doesn't
batman have supervision
because his parents died eh like
supervision
supervision apart never mind now i've
always considered the long halloween to
be the rise of the super villain
and in the movie we watches the mobsters
who run gotham city for years are slowly
ousted by something far more sinister
this motif and theme of the old ways
changing is too reflected in harvey dent
who we watch go from an upstanding d.a
to the supervillain two-face
throughout the films we see as harvey
wrestles with having to slowly break the
law
and make compromises in order to serve
the greater good
this split in his morals makes him split
internally and it's clear that he begins
to form his two-faced persona
even before it rears its ugly head or or
the face now the central plot of the
movie follows the main structure of the
graphic novel
and we watches a killer who strikes on
holidays slowly starts to wipe out
members of the mob
these are all connected to the falcone
or moroni crime family
and one by one the net closes in on them
as they attempt to get to the bottom of
who holiday is
now the first major change early on is
that bruce attends johnny vedi's wedding
at the beginning of the book
and it's revealed that this is to
actually spy on the crime boss
instead of simply meeting with him to
talk about gotham this scene in the book
was obviously playing on the opening of
the godfather
and the introductions to both don
corleone and falcone
are framed in very similar lights den
can even be found taking photographs of
the mobster's cause
similar to how the authorities did in
that movie now in the book right after
this
batman and catwoman both come face to
face in falcone's penthouse
which is where a ledger is discovered
that details all of his criminal
activities
it's quite an iconic scene so i was
surprised that they removed it
but i'm guessing that this is because
something similar appears to be
happening in the upcoming matt reeves
batman movie
in the book selena wishes to find out if
falcone is her father
but moments like this are removed in
order to make this a far more
self-contained story
in the comics selena actually goes off
into a side story called when in rome
in which she attempts to track down her
mother to confirm if the pair are
related
in the movie selena already knows that
falcone is her father
and she also swiftly avoids kissing
alberto
which yeah would have been very very
weird now this ledger is what leads
batman to the cash
and not selena who is the one that takes
him there in the film
he and harvey are the ones that attended
and catwoman
is much more of an ally in the
adaptation there also isn't a batmobile
chase as batman didn't have it at this
point
and he doesn't have a fight in a back
alley on the whole the main book is
actually pretty absent of action
with the detective story being the main
focus now what else gets expanded is the
stress that gilda den is subjected to
in the comics she seems like a pretty
normal housewife but here we really see
the absence that dent leaves in her life
due to his work commitments girl that
can often be found on her porch drinking
bottles of wine and smoking cigarettes
and i actually think the movie adds far
more motivation to the reveal
at the end mirroring this alberto's arc
gets completely changed
and in the comics it was revealed that
he was actually holiday
in the source material after the
incident on the boat it was shown that
alberto actually faked his own death
and that he had been carrying out
several of the assassinations
with gilda doing the others that
couldn't be explained calendar man even
teased at this in the work by changing
the pronouns of he and she
when discussing holiday interestingly
batman never suspected alberto
and he didn't confront him on new year's
eve instead alberto was apparently
killed
much like how the others were however
this was all a ruse
in the movie we watch his den attacks a
police convoy and batman unmasks
to reveal he's one of the swat team
members in the book it was at this
moment that he caught alberto instead
and it does make the ending
unpredictable even if you're familiar
with the source material
now the book t says that gilda could
have been involved in some of the
killings but here the source material is
changed massively to pin the entire
thing on her
the book never had a relationship
between her and alberto beforehand
and this is made up completely for the
animated movie so that we get some
surprises
in the source material alberto simply
wanted to get rid of the family
and gilda wanted to free up harvey's
work schedule so that they could have a
family
the two are completely unconnected but
the film has them as ex-lovers who were
split up by falcone
because he viewed her as being the wrong
woman because alberto was weak
he decided not to stand up to his dad
and thus he lived filled with regret for
the rest of his life
i will talk about that all later on in
the video as i wanted to address the
differences first
and in addition to the aforementioned
ones we have falcone calling bruce the
son that he never had
he and selena don't have as fleshed out
of a relationship and they don't know
one another's secrets
i think this is put in place to reflect
how harvey bruce
and gordon all place their duty above
their own happiness
and we see throughout the movie how they
suffer because of this now whereas
in the source material alberto was
driven on a quest for revenge
he is killed by holiday at the end of
part one part two feels a lot more in
line with the comics
and it opens with the poison ivy spell
which is followed by bruce's
hallucination
brought on by scarecrow both appear in
the source material
as do the circumstances in which thomas
wayne saved carmine
and the courtroom scene that turns
harvey into two-face almost happens beat
for beat
it's here that we're also introduced to
sophia who we'll be talking about later
on
as she plays a big part in the book
sequel doc victory
after moroni hands himself in as a
witness in order to stage a hearing
he throws acid and dense face and this
ushers forth to face
then flees the hospital and after
swimming through the sewers and somehow
not getting infected
he puts the pieces in place that lead to
moroni getting shot by holiday
then then springs arkham and rallies the
supervillains together
in order to replace the mafia they
attack gotham
and it all comes to a head up balcony's
penthouse which is of course where the
first movie started
batman and catwoman arrive and the two
sides face off against one another
harvey shoots falconi after using the
coin to decide his fate
and in his dying breath he calls selena
luiza which is
actually the name of his wife and her
mother sofia blames to death on her
sister catwoman
and after being thrown out of a window
the ladder seemingly falls to her death
however in the sequel comic dark victory
it's revealed that she's still alive
and she ends up taking over the falcone
organization
harvey hands himself in and the ending
of part two very much feels like a loss
as we see he succumbed to gotham and
what was needed in order to finally take
falcone down
batman questions if it was worth it and
this pushes him onto a much darker path
in which he decides to not work as
closely with the authorities
however he does come around after taking
dick grayson under his wing
and the follow-up is very much about
bringing bruce back into the light
so that he can trust people once more
the film ends with batman visiting gilda
and unlike the comics he finds out that
she was behind the holiday killings she
burns photographs of herself
and alberto knowing that coal mine
destroyed both of her relationships
it turns out that she and alberto were
married but valconi refused to bring a
child into the family that was conceived
out of wedlock
their marriage was annulled and the
child was taken from gilda's womb
because of this she wanted justice and
purposely married dent in order to
deliver this
she recognized the darker side within
him but when she realized nothing could
be done legally
she started the killings herself batman
ends up wrestling with whether to tell
gordon or not
and gilda's fate is left ambiguous in
the book she moves away and because we
don't hear from her
i think batman does let her go he
realizes that it's gonna take time
before things start to get better and we
see that a young child has been inspired
by batman
possibly hinting at a brighter future
coming in gotham now the post-credits
scene has green arrow and the flash
arrive at wayne manor
and though this movie was thought to be
disconnected from the greater universe
it does look like things could be
heading in a certain direction going
forward
they have likely come to form the
justice league and it is possible that
this will lead into him joining the team
i've also seen screenrant say that it is
possible that they are actually there
from the injustice universe
which is the next animated movie in that
book and game series
heroes travelled from a world in which
superman had turned evil
in order to recruit people from the
multiverse to stop him potentially
they're here to do that
though i do lean more towards it simply
being that they want him to start the
team
now at this point going forward i am
going to be spoiling dark victory and
what happens next
so if you don't want to know then turn
off now if you're enjoying the video i'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
swear to me you'll do it yeah swear to
me
i've always gotta have a really bad part
of the video and and that was that part
now after the events of the long
halloween the killings start once more
but this time they're against the police
carried out by a mysterious figure named
the hangman gotham pd
is ravaged and due to the ambiguity
around alberto's crime
he's put under house arrest the calendar
man escapes
and ends up sneaking into his house and
he talks to him through the walls which
sends him insane
during this the flying graysons are
killed and dick ends up joining bruce in
order to stop the hangman
sophia is seemingly wheelchair bound but
it's revealed that this is all a ruse
and that she can actually walk
she carries out the hangings in order to
get revenge and it leads to dick and
bruce becoming batman and robin
after they take her down bruce very much
saw harvey as betraying him
but in dick he sees there is good in the
world and who knows the kid at the end
might even be retconned to be him and
there's a lot to look forward to
and i really hope that they follow this
movie up with a sequel as i absolutely
loved it
i think it's one of the strongest
adaptations so far and the noir feeling
perfectly suits batman to a t
both part 1 and part 2 are brilliant and
because of that it gets a 9 out of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the movie and if you've also
read the book then let me know what you
preferred
just to let you know we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three mcu box sets on the 30th of july
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the films
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of why
sylvie was right at the end of loki
very controversial topic but i've
thought about it long and hard
and i actually side with what she did if
not then thank you for sitting until the
end of the video
i hope to see you next time and take
care of yourself peace